[Musique]
une chose est sûre en sortant une
chanson en solidarité avec les
personnels soignants dans le but de
récolter des fonds pour les hôpitaux en
cette période de crise sanitaire florent
pagny ne pensait certainement pas
s'attirer les foudres de nombreux
internautes
il ya quelques jours le chanteur
s'afficher aux côtés de marc lavoine et
pascal obispo dans le morceau pour les
gens du secours
[Musique]
les gens du
chevaux
et voilà si la tension est bonne pour
certains il s'agit là d'une opération de
communication qui n'est pas en
adéquation avec les agissements de
l'artiste dans le privé car il ya
quelques temps florent pagny avait avoué
s'installer au portugal pour sa
fiscalité beaucoup plus souple pour ses
internautes
refuser de payer des impôts en france
c'est refuser d'aider le service public
et l'hôpital des critiques virulentes
sur lequel a décidé de revenir florent
pagny visiblement atteint par ces
attaques
il en ressort un pour cent 1 % ce que
j'appellerai les irréductibles de
l'erreur qui m'envoient des messages
insultants
parce qu'ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
je suis sur ce projet caritatif alors
que je ne paye pas ses impôts en france
dans une vidéo postée sur instagram le
chanteur a indiqué qu'il payait une
grande partie de ses impôts en france
toutes prestations aux performances sur
le territoire français sera assujettie à
l'imposition française au tout français
est payable en france ce qui revient à
dire que 80% de mes revenus sont
imposables en france et pays en france
et vous comprenez vous les attaques
contre florent pagny alors est ce que
vous comprenez les attaques contre
florent pagny non matin je crois bah
maintenant je comprends mais non parce
que tint d'abord c'est pas le premier
artiste à optimiser son revenu fiscal
encore une fois il a raison que ce qu'on
gagne en france ses droits d'auteur
s'est payé en france donc ci contribue
évidemment à payer d'impôts en france et
c'est un faux procès parce
qu'effectivement florent pagny ça fait
des années qu'il est investi dans plein
de cause pourquoi lui faire un procès
maintenant il ya plein d'artistes on va
pas laisser patrons voient pas dévoilé
de le rappeler mais il ya plein
d'artistes en france qui font et qui se
barre à l'étranger parce qu'ils sont
effectivement deux semaines à un taux
qui considèrent trop élevé on peut pas
reprocher à ce mec là qui a toujours été
de toutes les causes c'est un
insupportable c'est un faux procès
allait prendre un petit strip six belges
sur twitter c'est une bonne oeuvre de
florent pagny s'il n'avait rien fait on
aurait dû pourquoi il alors à vos
florent pagny pour ta chanson bravo en
tout cas florent pagny pour sa réponse
sur un style sont plus tôt voilà les
gens disent que c'est quelqu'un
voilà qui est quelqu'un de généreux
cette chanson est magnifique qu'est ce
t'en penses heureux nettoie à laisser
les gens pensent que je suis absolument
outré par les cornes qui lui tombe
dessus parce que c'est tout c'est même
niveau voire les capteurs ou les restos
du coeur et comme il y en a
qui sonne dans les restos du coeur soit
disant qu'il faut les concerts etc
habitent ailleurs et qui se font payer
alors qu'on arrête avec florent pagny
tel super mec
bref chanteur val d'or dans l'ultime et
si on devine regardez johnny hallyday je
suis en demies en de mettre dans la rue
quelques il est bon alors je regrette
pas mieux mais qu'on arrête de faire des
procès aux jeunes mariés qui l'a dit si
servir ici la vérité alors on est au
dessus il fait lui santé dessus il a dit
que tout s'était dit ghanem et b ça
rentre dans les caisses
et basta et tu vois le karmapa comme pas
que les mecs il se posera le censeur
bouron avocat mathieu n'est pas toi
maintenant banon là pour une fois je
suis pas d'accord et dieu sait que je
défends les artistes mais là je suis pas
d'accord parce que florent pagny paie
aujourd'hui on peut pas en vouloir aux
gens et aujourd'hui son attitude du
passé je vous rappelle qu'à l'époque de
ma liberté
il devait plus sûr puisque je peux dire
ça alors justement parce que j'ai des
extraits de florent pagny de l'époque la
voilà voilà il a souvent eu des
problèmes avec le fisc en 97 il a été
poursuivi pour ne pas avoir déclaré il
payer pour près de 48000 euros
il avait été condamné à quinze mille
euros d'avancé en 2003 il répliquait
avec ma liberté de penser exactement 1
florent moi moi que je donne un peu
cernés est extrêmement généreux et
regarder chez thierry ardisson en 2005
il revenait sur 7
il revenait sur cette condamnation dans
tout le monde en parle il expliqué même
que heureusement que l'on paye des
impôts en france regard des délinquants
je suis pas quelqu'un qui suis pas un
tricheur donc à vendre pourquoi j'aurais
en plus une condamnation de prison même
avec sursis
bon avocat quand même non oui j'ai
finalement vu de bons avocats mais en
même temps parce qu'à un moment il faut
quand même intégré un système que tout
le monde ne connaît pas donc il faut
pouvoir le dénouer et même en étant
innocent il faut pouvoir quand même le
prouver
maintenant j'ai une baguette pages où
vivent des chorales et
d'impôts alors après en 2017 et
s'installe au portugal en expliquant que
son pot c'est pour de vraies raisons
fiscales et alors qu'il est en pleine
tourmente médiatique voilà parce qu'il
est parti il se justifie dans sept à
huit en expliquant que ceux qui le
critiquent donc à gagner beaucoup
d'argent c'est ce qu'il avait dit
florent pagny pour revenir sur les
propos de malek certaines personnes que
j'ai choqué par le fait qu on essaye
d'optimiser son impôt quand on gagne
beaucoup d'argent
ben ils ont qui a gagné beaucoup
d'argent et après on verra comment il se
comportera
ça c'est à mon avis d espèce de délire
de jalousie ou dans vie parce que
quelque part un moment on se dit qu'on y
arrivera peut-être jamais alors
finalement on déteste celui qui peut y
accéder en tout cas tout le monde défend
un florent pagny faut les résoudre un
sur twitter un soul dis bravo à florent
pagny qui a raison de se défendre contre
les ignorants comme d'habitude florent
pagny est un gars entier qui dit ce
qu'il pense bravo à lui et c'est vrai
que c'est un gars entier florent pagny
c'est un super mec et lui donne je peux
dire à mon goût
maintenant je peux dire à moka est moins
facile c'est peut-être un super mec mais
comment en vouloir aux gens je vous
rappelle que donc à l'époque quand il de
l'argent au fisc qui s'est arrangé pour
pour devenir insolvable il avait tout
mis au nom d'un copain à lui parce qu'on
puisse pas les prendre de l'argent à la
suite de ça il annonce qui part au
portugal pour les opus call et ensuite
dans sept à huit il dit qu'effectivement
et gagnent beaucoup de pognon il
insulter les gens qui ne gagnent pas
donc si tu veuilles ce thème tous pour
qu'on lui tombe dessus aujourd'hui et
pour qu'on lui fasse un procès en impôts
pas pardon ça on peut pas reprocher à
raison mon jardin ont fait une alliée
regarder les jolies
je ne comprends pas l'acharnement sur
florent pagny moi je dois bien de
l'argent aux impôts aussi mais en
fonction de mes revenus et alors
n'oublions pas sa liberté
on lui tombe toujours dessus à florent
pagny de toute façon bravo à lui et
belle initiative
c'est pas le seul à avoir quitté la
france pour des raisons fiscales nous
c'est vrai que il fait et fait un truc
pour le bétail et y prend le temps y est
on si on lui tombe dessus alors y avoir
de ces cas là on va être sur les mecs
qui font rien et bagus budi taksim
je trouve qu'on mélange tout faut qu'on
laisse tranquille dès que florent pagny
quelque chose en france de voice un
nouvel album une nouvelle prise de
parole on est tombé dessus pour ses
histoires d'impôts après il a dit c'est
un pour cent des commentaires et cette
minorité la caisse qui veulent que
chacun s'arrête compagnie restent en
hausse après des données qu'il fait à ce
que rien franchement c'est du délit de
sale gueule et bien mais
et pas à la polémique qui ce calme et à
la solidarité honte à ces laideurs
franchement allez on va voir ce qu'en
pensent les téléspectateurs seront pas
tous voilà on va on va clore ce débat là
dessus qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on pour
ses téléspectateurs
là dessus et juste alors oui
comprenez vous oui à 21% n'ont à 79%
donc vous êtes une large majorité à ne
pas comprendre les attaques sur florent
pagny très vite géraldine ce qu'on a et
ça me fait penser à quelqu'un vous aussi
parfois on vous attaque on dit que votre
générosité envers les téléspectateurs et
suspecte vous faites à par opportunisme
est toujours une sorte de suspicion
étrange et bizarre quand les gens font
des bonnes d'actions à l'écran comme je
disais ma gg il
quand tu fais rien quand on dit que rien
quand tu fais on va dire à baida fait
parce que ils voulaient relate laurent
pagny en tout cas il a eu le mérite de
faire quelque chose bravo à lui et le
titre est magnifique moyen ce que j'ai à
dire voilà après voilà on il a fait
appel a pu faire des erreurs mais
aujourd'hui